hi guys i am back playing friend bow
once again last time we left off we got
to talk to the mountain and we were
going to be little matchmakers and get
him back with his girlfriend wife i
don't know the little island so let's
see if we can do that let's go because
we want that magic hat don't we oh I
know you are all alone
let me be your mommy let me feed you
what are you gonna feed me come to my
side uh mr. midnight don't go towards
there and you will have many new friends
to play with they um they kind of know a
little Jokers with that smile I don't
think they're actually happy I don't
want you as my money my money my mummy
you're very scary I don't like you Fran
who are you talking to Oh mr. bin I
can't see them huh the woman standing uh
it's nothing kitty Oh kitty you don't
understand you understand the problems
of little Franz oh right let's go and
find his little wife
and then we can get them together we can
fix their broken relationship look at
your ears the cat's already scared cuz
it's like no no no don't drop it don't
drop me
okay let's talk to the little mountain
hey there hello miss wake up I have a
message for you hello a messenger what a
good day oh my gosh this is lame yes
miss I'm the messenger of love in love
oh but you are not pink uh should I be
pink
oh should I be pink I have to use human
skin though I saw was pink oh it used to
have human skin hmm and does the
messenger of love have something to
share she's not impressed yes of course
I'm here in the name of love to bring
you back to your husband no he made me
very sad nobody has the right to make me
sad what did he do tell me tell me on
the gossip I wanted other things well
maybe he didn't mean to harm you what
did he do he was so hot and I fell in
love with that oh yeah he's built he's
filled with lava but lately he was cold
and boring ah not there's the whole bad
boy thing so I felt left aside I cried
so many times he used to draw a
beautiful red flower just for me to show
his love for me but this year nothing
came up okay and you know what I am the
one protecting him all the time so I
once a credit for that that's all hmm I
have the flower I picked up didn't I use
it as one of those magic key things but
miss if I find that flower for you would
you come back and I guess they have no
hope besides I'm the ruler of my own
now I'll come and see if I can find my
flower
I think ina habit I might haven't always
at the bottom it's very different from
all the flowers oh okay
maybe not my husband's bottom of course
breeds me I'll hear it I do have the
flower even realize I plucked it from
its bottom I guess it is yes the bottom
of the mount isn't it miss I found it
look look the red flower No thank you so
much it looks beautiful
you are indeed a great messenger of
level thank you miss we should go back
to your husband right away how is she
gonna get back to the husband how did
she get away from the last minute to
begin with he misses you I'll see you
there in winter time oh wow show some
skills yeah Winston
hey there she is now she's gone hey it's
very nice to see you two together
oh there she is she's right behind me
now I'd like to have the hat please
thank you very much I never forget what
you've done for us
come on my darling climb on to the job
ah true love and here's the Hat thank
you again thanks that's a cool cool hat
looks like it's got looks my knees on
thank you sir I have to go and give the
hat back to the great wizard now that's
cute they're in love again kind of
weirdly she's like sewed onto the top of
him is a bit gross actually if you
thinking
okay what do I do now give the hat back
to the guy and then I think you can turn
this into a human here's your hat sir oh
my heart I feel the knowledge blowing
through my body I feel happy
that's great sir what's next the gift
from the soil the food
the creation of selected random elements
so we can eat beautiful isn't it
yes that's incredible yes the fruit is
talking to me now it says the book the
book of knowledge it's in the library
but where where the library the book may
be hiding so you have to be persistent
and patient well we've been patient
enough with this game have a weed so I'm
sure we can we can be patient for a
little bit longer I'll go to the library
wait
there's a password oh this is where okay
okay you'll need to get it sighs let me
think it must be something about how we
learn or hmm I remember password is your
basic senses are easily manipulated shut
them down before learning what does it
even mean it means that many times we
let our understanding me manipulated we
should always try to use our common
sense nobody should ever tell you what
to think or believe there you go people
in school keep that money no I'm not
gonna say that don't dropping out stay
in school kids stay in school be hungry
for knowledge and you'll find yourself
in constant evolution that's why - I
totally believe now I love learning
stuff that will make you forever cherish
every second of your life cool let's go
so every time I put something in there
ho-jon we can have to have to find
something new this is not like a long
time but it's all right we can find it
I'm still confused by the creepy
elements because I thought the only
happened once you take the pills the
stuff is happening without how we've
been taking you now so
I think she's just going crazy she is a
tree maybe she'll be better when she's
not a tree here we go oh my god I didn't
even see these houses here
do you remember friend you are you are
naughty little girl
nutty girls must be punished is that
naughty or naughty
Oh do as I say
do as I do friend jump don't
Oh No you didn't kill your family I
don't want to kill them I didn't want to
don't listen to those evil things you're
strong listens miss midnight get them
out of you I had my dear crazy kitty
tell me I did kind of just call her
crazy I feel bad now no idea you just
have to be strong don't let them play
with your head oh my kitty I feel
completely broken my chest hurts no idea
I'm here for you don't cry so what
happens if you walk over to there now we
should keep on going well this is a bit
scary
okay yeah I was like do we get the
option to jump no good that means she
doesn't want to at least that's a good
thing stop like that do you have a
password yes yes I do
what's the password something like your
eyes and ears limited what no no that
wasn't the password was it did I
actually just not okay because only then
we can really see it's like a city it
was invisible to me before knowledge is
ever opening okay I guess it's just
along the same lines let's go in the
library I love books look at their arm
the vegetables love books do look at the
Dragonfly hello Sam what are you doing
here I'm looking for my special look I
took nice things like that
oh sorry to ask why you standing on a
ladder you have wings because the ladder
was made to be used of course oh yes
very true that's a good point
but what if I need to use it that's a
very good point too
then you should wait your turn but what
if it's an emergency and I can't wait
that much then you should have arrived
already of the Me's sorry but I have to
keep looking me all right maybe it's
this but it's just the line there for us
this is grant
it must be artists and numbers yes one
two and three and four and so on that's
cool Oh wasn't this somewhere oh yeah
yeah it was um when we were trying to
find other little ingredient things I
just have to remember them what's that
pushing well work dear try to unlock it
instead unlock miss
the one with the buttons right next to
you you know the east-west lock no but
yeah but I don't worry now that sounds
familiar
of course it sounds familiar it's it's
Bert we're talking about
he's quite a creature can you believe he
made that look just for fun okay ask me
if you using how oh okay hmm so I need
to remember the numbers
it's a puzzle girl so you talk to carrot
guy can you tell me the right
combination for the dark no miss I can't
I haven't learnt it at that school oh
he's a little boy no miss I can't I
haven't learned that at school yet oh
and what was the special book you're
reading about it's about two bunnies
making dinner and then three of their
friends came over so then there are five
bunnies eating dinner they eat carrots
they eat carrots are you not scared by
that of course they do their bunnies
hmm it looks like they're having fun I
hope they are hmm okay
what a beautiful book yes now I'd like
to keep reading please sorry le villain
hello side body
yes dear what's wrong I need ya help
with the symbols what are the symbols on
the last symbols are a numeric system
you know one two three oh I see thank
you yeah but I need to I don't know what
numbers I need I'm sorry dear
we know what the King told you you have
to do it all by yourself it's quite
simple really easy as adding one and one
together all right I have no clue so I
just have to like maybe just count up
one there are two ones I don't know I'm
not very good at this type of puzzle but
I can't take it away maybe adding them
up so 1 1 2 2 1 1 is 4 I think that's
what I think is that's all
yeah that's 4 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
16 16 bloody L was 16 did I'm not gonna
lie I don't know if any of you know let
me know because I don't really know what
I was doing there
but it worked so let's progress yeah
yeah c'mon sucking your puzzles wait
it's just a music whoa bloody ell what
jump scares and Fran bow that's another
thing ah
did not expect that this must be their
was its Berg yeah I need the ladder
brilliant it's always something to climb
on is there maybe I should change
seasons
oh yeah cuz he said that I should be
there early uh Wu Wei got see this game
huh jump scares are you ready for it
boom
yeah go away you're creepy thing sweet
we got it that's a skeleton with a top
hat very very observant young lady right
let's go all right mr. magician I got
your book so here's your book it was
inside the musical box
I saw the doll here it would lock that
sounds like fun
thank you for the book this certainly
makes me remember many things many many
things
and now uh there are two things after
the star yes fish in the water
I'm determined to make her our human
this episode
fish fish swimming free go back little
fish go home today you woke up the fish
yes because I remember too how to do it
isn't that beautiful
it's magical can you share with other
beings like humans Oh fan of course but
I don't need the circumstances are
positive if the circumstances are not up
and these circumstances are not often
positive I see what so they need to be
killed for the right purpose I guess hmm
so we need to find the missing stones
yes the fish told me that my shoes are
on the feet of this amazing dancer okay
do you know where this dancer could be I
have no idea
ah maybe in the club dancing it up
because there are dancers you know I
know I'll go and see but I can't get in
there so I don't know dancer
oh yeah so don't have a ticket to go
into the bar you don't have your ticket
that's odd
may I borrow your ticket can I borrow
your ticket my ticket is mine I can't
lend it and then go inside the by
yourself and take the shoes of the
dancer that's very true
I can't I'm making rabbit science and
I'm pretty close to the answer
besides I know you can do it you
completed some very difficult tasks
already all right I'll see what I can do
wonder if I can get in there before
opens anyway anyway it's all logs here
there's a hole awesome how do we get in
there that howls tiny come on kit you go
inside and remember I need a ticket to
get into so maybe you can take somebody
else's but I don't want to steal oh just
borrow it we can give it back later
right all right thanks kitty yeah Oh mr.
midnight nah look at him he's so cute
yeah okay this is a cool bomb all that
scary giant fleas no thank you
yeah you don't want them sucking off
your blood how are we gonna get a kick
out of someone that's the dancer oh yeah
I'm off I used to eat those but I won't
this time I think that moth is a tad too
big for you this ladybug is the tiniest
I've seen around
besides of flies that's fast hand oh
here we go here's a ticket I see a
ticket I can't take it now it's being
used hello lady can I borrow your ticket
please my ticket disappeared
and I'm using it as a coaster oh this
lemonade's very good that's not lemonade
that's not lemonade guys don't be fooled
but why you have a table to put the
glass on I don't like the sounds of the
glass against the table I see and you
like this lemonade very much right yes I
drink it because it's it refreshing now
if you'll excuse me oh if you excuse me
I went to listen to the music of course
goodbye
stupid drunken wasp okay well let's get
a coaster for a little friend surely the
bartender would have some spare coasters
Oh No apparently not we need to find a
coaster do we have something else oh no
I can't give her that what about this
you can use this as a coaster no no it
doesn't know what to do with that what
about this
now how about the change of season I lay
the dance is dancing he's still cool
well haha he stole my dance moves guys
that's how I dance yeah anyway yes
stupid drunken drunken wasp got drunk
off lemonade
they made him vodka or rum perhaps here
we go we got our ticket so good ok I had
the ticket I have it you're incredible I
love you now we go outside yeah oh yeah
not that way well I got my ticket sir ok
did you find your ticket oh yeah I gotta
give it to you yeah let me in this can't
be why you just can't I already let
someone in with that ticket you bring
many mysteries in lady symbols are
correct but look at the handwriting this
belongs to someone much older than you I
can see it no so any chance I can get
inside I mean is it possible when you
have your own ticket little lady you're
more than welcome this is not fair what
do we do with it maybe use a crayon on
tickets make it look like someone a lot
younger has you on it no I won't draw on
it
I need my own ticket what the bloody
hell I just created my own ticket and
it's not legit at all it's that doesn't
even look like Fran ticket Fran and
Kitty can go in Party Party number two
okay let's see if this works
looks sad I think this is my own ticket
no I see but you simply drew it yourself
I thought it was the right thing to do I
wasn't invited so I invited myself make
clever little lady well I guess I can
let you in guys if you can't go into a
club
don't pull those painting loads of money
for fake ID just for drawing crayon and
just tell the bouncers you weren't
invited see don't even write yourself
and you never know you might be let in
one okay we should probably wait till
he's finished dancing
I need your shoes okay he's concentrate
do I think Oh her head hello dancer
mister I really need to take your shoes
I don't know why she turned into a way
dance and then and why's this the shoes
belong to a dancer I'm a dancer I'm a
dancer I need them to dance with the
wizard who I'm sorry what did you just
say I want your shoes you wonder what I
did eliminate you seem to be a little
tense
no sir I don't want lemonade why don't
you get your shoes boom hmm you should
drink a little lemonade at least it's on
your thirst I don't know why I'm doing
this weird accent for him sir let me
explain I need your shoes
needs them oh but that's impossible I
can't give you my shoes the only way to
get my shoes is to take them from me
and as you can see now I'm standing them
so that's impossible
but if you lift your feet I could take
them mmm
it can't be done the only only the very
day when both of my feet are up in the
air only then can my shoes be taken
otherwise I will stand forever hmm I see
okay so we gotta wait until he's dancing
let me take off my shoes come on sir
take up those shoes when are you gonna
have both of them up in the air at the
same time
take his bloody shoes
can I use a tool to like know what okay
I'm not sure how we're supposed to know
this but if you click once and it goes
to winter you get automatically put
outside the bar if you double-click
quickly it goes to the season where it's
all barricaded outside so we can now
change the piano how do we do this what
do we want to do with this
I guess just put it all in here into
here yeah so it's super slow so when he
jumps we'll have enough time to click
his feet I think probably wall we'll see
oh my god it did completely the opposite
oh wow okay he fell over yes give me
your true who's there my I had the shoes
I'm so clever let's take them to the
wizard yeah you are clever I do feel
clever great party the dancing was
rubbish let's go
and the shoes shoes for the wizard whoa
make me a human sir sir I had the shoes
they're very pretty look wow you did it
you really have an extraordinary machine
inside your head thank you sir
now let's do the last one so I can go
home the last one
I recognized his head
it belongs to pelant Russ yes I saw him
really injured
he'll be fine he has the pink water that
can fix everything
yeah it's true well what do we do with
the feather
he'ii go visit the old volakis and
mechanical doll my wand will be there i
I have to finish my rabbit science
oh okay so I'll bring you one back okay
guys I think I'm gonna leave it there
now let's go find the Wizards wand in
the next episode we need to be human
again
and I'm very interested to find out more
about these odd creepy happenings and
why they're still happening I guess it
wasn't the pills I guess it was just the
state of Franco's mind I'm not saying
she's crazy in this thing she's very
distraught she's been through a lot so
let's help her through even more in the
next episode have a little bit
everything
fine I'm sorry I got me close I have the
one thing you desire I have what you're
looking for with them um I was gonna
joke